d'un me catherine procaccia pour le
groupe ump
merci monsieur le président remercie mes
chers collègues madame la ministre au
cours des vingt dernières années les
circuits de fabrication du médicament
ont complètement changé d'une
fabrication quasiment nationale des
principes actifs excipients par un petit
nombre d'acteurs
identifiés et connus des autorités
l'importation des médicaments a
littéralement explosé la france importe
pour près de 22 milliards d'euros de
médicaments contre 9 milliards en l'an
2000 un rapport de l'académie de
médecine indiqué que 50% des princeps et
80% des principes actifs des génériques
et est dorénavant fabriquées en asie le
cas du paracétamol est particulièrement
frappant cet antidouleur le plus vendu
au monde est fabriqué à 100 % hurd hors
d'europe les changements économiques ont
été si rapide que le seul contrôle des
autorités compétentes ne peut plus
sécurisé la fabrication des médicaments
en effet là et même est une femme
procédures d'accès sur le marché et les
contrôles effectués par le mehdi par le
fabricant se font par des évaluations
ils ne sont donc forcément pas exhaustif
qui plus est les normes de bonnes
pratiques ne sont pas harmonisées dans
le monde car elles sont très coûteuses
et donc forcément pas appliquée tel est
le cas de l'héparine qui a beaucoup
défrayé la chronique
quant au contrôle sur les sites ils sont
trop hexagonaux sur 896 inspection en
2010 seulement 85 concernaient des sites
étrangers certes à partir de juillet
pour lutter contre les imports de
principes actifs frauduleux les
laboratoires devront fournir une
attestation de conformité aux critères
européens pour tous les produits
importés mais celle ci sera établi par
les pays exportateurs eux-mêmes et ne
réglera donc pas la question de la
méfiance lié à l'absence de contrôle
actuellement seul le nom du titulaire
exploitants figure sur l'emballage
personne ne connaît donc l'origine des
matières premières ni si le médicament a
subi des contrôles
madame la ministre elle vous favorable
l'inscription sur les boîtes de
l'origine des matières premières ainsi
que du pays de conditionnement et
quelles mesures comptez vous prendre
pour encourager les industriels du
médicament notamment génériques à
rétablir la confiance merci la parole à
madame marisol touraine
monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice catherine procaccia je vous
remercie de la manière dont vous avez
posé la question
très mesuré dans un climat qui
risque toujours de déraper moi je veux
le dire avec beaucoup de force nos
concitoyens doivent avoir confiance dans
la qualité des médicaments qui leur sont
proposées ce n'est pas parce que il y a
eu des fraudes ce n'est pas parce que il
y a des interrogations où il y a eu des
interrogations sur certains médicaments
qu'il faut jeter l'opprobre sur
l'ensemble de la production
pharmaceutique et de ce point de vue là
les médicaments génériques sont des
médicaments dans lesquels on peut avoir
confiance il y a qu'en france que l'on
s'interroge sur la qualité des
médicaments génériques qui sont
fabriqués dans les mêmes conditions
j'insiste là dessus dans les mêmes
conditions que les médicaments princeps
il est exact qu au cours des dernières
années la production des matières
premières s'est déplacé dans des pays
hors union européenne en particulier en
asie mais c'est également vrai pour les
matières premières qui composent les
médicaments princeps et donc tout
l'enjeu est à la fois de favoriser la
relocalisation de certaines activités de
production sur le territoire européen et
si possible sur le territoire national
et une discussion est engagée avec la
filière pharmaceutique précisément dans
le cadre du comité de filière pour voir
comment nous pouvons pour les
médicaments et des filières stratégiques
faire en sorte que la production soit
relaxe relocaliser dans notre pays et
nous devons par ailleurs c'est le
deuxième axe de travail faire en sorte
que les contrôles la garantie de
contrôle efficace soit renforcé ses
contrôles ils sont menés niveau européen
ils sont menés au niveau national des
normes sont imposés qui se diffuse
progressivement au niveau mondial c'est
ainsi que nous parviendrons à rétablir
la confiance et au delà une réflexion
est engagée avec l'industrie
pharmaceutique pour voir jusqu'à quel
point des informations pourraient être
apportés aux patients qui n'est pas
qu'un consommateur qui est impatient
jusqu'à quel point des informations
pourraient lui être apportés directement
sur la boîte lorsqu'ils achètent cette
boîte ces discussions sont en cours et
je pense que nous pourrons aboutir à des
mesures destinées à renforcer encore une
fois la confiance de nos concitoyens
merci maman progressium
merci madame la ministre entre votre
réponse à alain milon et à la mienne
vous répondez en partie à la question
puisque nous estimons aussi que s'il ya
des problèmes d'approvisionnement c'est
bien parce que les principes actifs et
les médicaments proviennent beaucoup de
très loin et que lorsqu'il y à des
contrôles dans ces pays là justement ça
retarde les fournisseurs et ça pose un
vrai problème pour des médicaments
beaucoup plus important que qu'un
certain nombre de médicaments qui sont
en france il y avait
auparavant il ya encore en france 224
usines de fabrication il y en avait
beaucoup plus dans l'an 2000 et
malheureusement sur les 47 médicaments
qui ont été autorisés sur le marché
européen l'année dernière aucun n'était
fabriqué en france donc vous parler de
re laquelle relocalisation de travailler
avec l'industrie pharmaceutique
je crois effectivement que ramener un
certain nombre d' usine en france de
fabrication en france et aussi permettre
à ces entreprises et à sein des
industries de proposer des nouveaux
médicaments irait dans le bon sens